I won't become
[Music]
The View I'm breaking through the glass
[Music]
she's so sweet she's so unaffected and
it's not even something she wants to do
I asked her I said do you want to take
singing lessons she's like no I'm
already good at it and I was like but
you can be better
because everyone can always be better
but Pink's daughter Willow sounds pretty
good in her first recital
[Music]
fans of High School Musical the musical
the series know this one
all my life I've seen myself Through
Your Eyes
cause Willows belting Olivia Rodrigo's
season two track the roll song you tell
me that I'm beautiful but I think that's
an understatement
[Music]
come to you foreign
[Music]
blows me away and as Mandy Moore put it
in the comments quote holy cow what a
voice what composure Superstar
[Music]
and Willow's chops are no surprise she
was breaking down her theater credits
for E.T just last month so my daughter
just got done doing grease in her
theater production and she actually
helped me learn the song did that was
she Sandy no she was no
it's like a show that I'm the youngest
person so I was Ensemble yeah did you
love it I did it I did that same show
last year just Mama me instead of us
well Willows moved on from Broadway hits
and landed on Nene's ballad from season
two of the hit Disney plus series
[Music]
Mimi's a theater kid which is awesome
because I was totally a theater kid
growing up yeah so Willow's in good
company as she gets a head start on her
singing career she's already released
music with her mom cover me in sunshine
showing me with good times so maybe her
own albums not too far off
I
[Music]
am
how do you feel when you see Willow sing
I think it's great I love when she sings
I mean she has you know your voice and
both of our athleticisms and she's not
as crazy as me which is good so I think
she's safer on uh behind a microphone
put me in as my buildings from within
[Applause]
[Music]